[Music]
[Music]
hey I'm mark and I'm here at the boot
camp section of Google cloud NEX where
we've got thousands of technical
practitioners and developers here to
learn a new skill or get Google cloud
certified attendees can check out
trainings take hands-on labs or get
assessed for Google cloud certification
of course each lifelong learning journey
is a unique one so let's talk to some of
the folks who have been Google cloud
certified I chose to get a Google
certified crime winner to have a very
good knowledge on Google cloud also to
have a confidence especially when you
interact with clients or even within a
company when you want to build a system
to have that confidence
I choose Google cloud certification to
get gained the trust of my clients that
I had the technical skills to build the
best data pipelines and the
architectures for their business
requirements so it shows to be certified
because there is a real a real value for
certification on the market every
company is really looking for that and
if you want to walk in the crowd you
have to have certifications part of it
was knowing that the Google cloud
platform has been growing exponentially
I thought this was the best time to be
well aligned with such an environment in
technology and get that certification
for Google Cloud
but the certification process doesn't
stop there they're taking their
teachings back with them to help their
own teams start on their learning
journeys from the certification right I
wanted to gain more and more learning
from my fellow Google cloud certified
team and Googlers or to learn more real
world use cases
so part of it has been career growth on
mass
has been a huge spike from the clients
that have been reaching out to me and
I've also worked with the team of about
for my team members and woodall dedicate
a lot of time to studying and learning
the whole Google Cloud suite of products
that they have to make sure that we're
prepared for the certification hopefully
this inspires you to start your own
learning journey down Google cloud
certification and seeing what you can
build
[Music]
you
[Music]